le
bonjour mon nom répond james corentin
pardon au pardon excusez moi c'est parce
que j'ai un petit neveu qui s'appelle
corentin je suis très content de vous
voir
j'ai justement quelque chose à vous
faire essayer non parce que sinon ça
laisse des traces
je vous présente le ballet téléphone n'a
pas autre chose si si bien sûr autre
chose non il n'ya pas 12 me sorte de
ballet non plus n'en met pas un ballet
justement quelque chose de plus petit
alors pourquoi je suis donc content du
faucon qui êtes vous
bon on a un gros problème de discrétion
la jeune agent secret moi j'ai besoin de
passer incognito n'en dit pas plus
il est parti par là je suis déjà que
l'irak sera d'accord bon je te laisse il
ya mon petit neveu qui est là bon alors
premièrement je suis pas votre neveu et
deuxièmement va falloir faire un effort
nouveau gadget puisque sinon moi je vais
chez leroy merlin bonbons un sac à dos
jetpack ça vous ferait plaisir
j'ai oublié de lui donner un gilet pare
balles en même temps qui a pas de raison
qu'ils aient besoin d'un gilles pas
voilà
ou est-ce qui est passé
alors là bravo c'est m'a sauvé mais
c'est parfait pour jouer dehors ça
regardez moi ça ils sont tous dégoûtant
maintenant je vais le dire à tata knicks
désolé je suis obligé de vous poser la
question mais vous avez bien compris que
je suis pas votre nouveau ben oui sinon
sujet du jetpack
il ya un petit délai avant que le moteur
chauffe
je suis ton peur